the super low-budget found-footage
blockbuster Paranormal Activity used its
rickety style as a badge of honor
positively terrifying audiences around
the world with the simple question
what's happening in my house while I'm
asleep let's find the answer within the
untold truth of paranormal activity
squeaky floor director Oren Peli came up
with the idea for the movie after being
a little freaked out by the routine
creaks and squeaks in his new home
he told Newsweek I don't think it was
anything supernatural a lot of it was
natural stuff like the house settling
but that's what got me thinking what
goes on when you're asleep
DIY filmmaking before making paranormal
activity Pelle had never worked on a
movie before so how did he do it simple
he spent most of his tiny budget buying
the camera equipment and taught himself
how to film edit and add special effects
then film the whole thing in a single
week inside his own house Pelley's motto
just go with it
I knew ahead of no money no experience
no no lighting you know none nothing and
only one location so I said okay so the
movie will embrace all of that and Pelle
avoided the need to learn screenwriting
with a pretty simple solution no script
instead he gave these actors topics to
discuss and let them improvise the rest
the director told shocked til you drop
that all they knew is they were going to
do something about a haunted house and
basically discovered everything as they
were shooting there were no lines for
them to follow everything was
spontaneous close encounter since Pelle
didn't have any Hollywood connections or
experience he headed to the film
festival circuit to build some buzz only
to be rejected by Sundance and by this
studio system we managed to saw the
movie
a lot of the heads of studios and be
rejected by all of them he didn't give
up though screening the film at smaller
film festivals for nearly two years
before finally landing a distribution
deal with Steven Spielberg's DreamWorks
studio that was one problem though
Spielberg didn't like the original
ending which showed Katy being shot by
police instead he came up with the idea
for the ending you saw in the theaters
with Katie's demonic face seared into
your retinas forever so you can blame
your nightmares on Spielberg paranormal
reactivity when DreamWorks picked up the
film the plan was to remake it with
bigger stars and bigger budget but as
part of the contract the Los Angeles
Times reports pally and producer Jason
Blum required the studio to hold at
least one test screening of the original
cut before pulling the trigger on the
remake to see if audiences liked it when
viewers at the test screening started
walking out of the theater midway
through the film it looked bad with
studio exec Adam Goodman calling it one
of the worst previews he'd ever been a
part of until the exit interviews showed
the attendees were leaving because they
were too terrified to keep watching it
just like that a hit was born infectious
belly was clearly inspired by the Blair
Witch Project not just in terms of style
and budget but also viral marketing case
in point
he kept the stars katie featherston and
mika slope hidden away in the hopes that
it might help generate some extra
mystery Pelle told the Los Angeles Times
he made the decision because the less
people know about paranormal activity
the more they enjoy it I don't think
there's anything to be gained by putting
the filmmakers and the cast in front so
much money it's scary
if you thought demonic possession was
frightening
here's something even more terrifying
math
with a worldwide return of 193 million
dollars Paranormal Activity boasts an
absurd 1.28 million percent return on
its initial $15,000 budget that profit
margin is more than double the return
earned by the second most profitable
film ever which was that's right the
Blair Witch Project time to get your
GoPro go downstairs and make some back
come on haunting Steven Spielberg is
responsible for some of the biggest
scares ever thanks to jaws but even he
was terrified by paranormal activity
thanks in part to a supernatural
experience he had while screening the
DVD somehow his bedroom door wound up
locked from the inside
that coupled with the freakiness of the
movie weak doubt the legendary director
so much that he put the DVD in a trash
bag when he returned it the next day so
he wouldn't have to physically touch it
surprising he didn't just feed it to the
Sharks
Japanese spin-off Paranormal Activity
has spawned half-a-dozen follow-ups and
spin-offs but there's one that stands
out as a curious black sheep among the
franchise Tokyo Knight around the same
time Paranormal Activity 2 was being put
together for us release the studio
license to the franchise out for a
parallel sequel for release in Japan
which follows a Japanese student who
brings the spirit back to Tokyo
following a trip to San Diego
sorry Japan thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what scared you the most about
paranormal activity